so this question is mainly for Jeff and
I know a lot of fans will be asking you
this question as well what's the maxi
time sorry you're the voice and next
time we will see Derek a good question
the skate was all I could answer that
actually should call hoechlin would that
be crazy I'd call him right now
call him and say when the hell are you
getting your ass back to Teen Wolf you
should probably let him know he's a
speaker are you all calling him because
then it's not gonna work okay yep I got
Holland be calling I'm calling a fish
that's gonna be a crazy view of the
answers it's gonna be like oh oh oh yeah
can I turn around over the day like I'm
right it's bringing Tyler hoechlin his
eyes I don't know what's gonna happen I
will tell you I will tell you that
answer it's up to him
so tweet him tweet him and tell him get
your ass back to Teen Wolf
you guys know my god this is crazy
something hello hello
it's uh how do I suppose I say we're
told me we are on the Teen Wolf panel at
comic-con right now when you're on
speaker and you're fed through the
microphone say something to the fans can
you hear this I can I can't probably
that I could die do you miss you do you
everyone wants to know do you miss Derek
do you miss Derek everyone wants to know
I really do I can't really he's overseas
right now it's like 4:00 in the morning
all right homie I think everyone just
everyone just wanted to hear that I love
you wait horn scene was a good time and
I could give it a lot of love yet with
that
Stillman will give you call them to text
us
that was cool right
you